yo it was good fun this week on thug
notes we separating wheat from chaff
with the crucible I often know things
ain't right up in 1692 Massachusetts
well Reverend Parris is baby girl Betty
and bed straight clock down see last
night Paris big Betty freaking out
begging like with her cousin Abigail and
slave Tituba and now word on the street
it's witchcraft be involved and uptight
peeps of Salem ain't having none of that
when the plays hero John Proctor rolls
in to see what's what Abigail gets all
up on this baby making like ugly Oh your
mom apparently Abigail used to be
practice made but got her ass tossed out
when Proctor's wife Elizabeth found her
shine and more than progress shoes Oh
straight scandalous even though Proctor
Ben dog and Abigail since then she still
think that if Elizabeth was out of the
picture she'd be his new wife later word
come that home he's getting accused of
witchcraft left and right turns out
Abigail playing dirty and say Elizabeth
there sipping that witch's juice so the
fuzz get all up and practice grilled and
throw her ass behind bars
so prop the bus is in the court to free
is booth but all that real talk
backfires and get his ass thrown in the
big house and the only way out is by
lying and admitting that he part of the
devil's posse product that keeps it og
and don't play that game until he gets a
visit from his honey dip Elizabeth and
eventually he decides to fess up that
something he ain't even do when the law
start saying they're gonna need a
written confession so they can show all
the hood
Proctor says he'll know cuz he ain't
gonna let them use his name on the
street like that so he tears that up
struts up to the gallows and goes out
like a gangster
not only is this play flowing about
events that really took place back in a
day but Miller also peppers some parable
up in here
see Miller wanted to give a big you the
1950s McCarthyism a time when the whole
bunch of Americans started pointing
fingers at their own peeps and the name
of trying to sniff out any cons and in
Miller's mind those snitch America's
only know guilty and not guilty like
he's saying I was as a divided Empire
with certain ideas and emotions and
actions are of God and their opposites
are of Lucifer the political policy is
equated with a moral right and
opposition to it with diabolical
malevolence see the problem up in here
is people always viewing things and
extremes to them it's all black and
white which means that it's something
eight of God then it must be able to
double so what starts out as political
opposites turns into moral opposites
then crooked right wingers have made it
so that capitalists are all holy and
communist ain't nothing but devil
worshippers but a dangerous political
power plays people trying to pawn
sometimes you just gotta stab a brother
in the back but dress it up like you're
doing the world of faith long-held
hatred of neighbors could now be openly
expressed and binges taken
despite the Bible's charitable
injunctions what you know about this
plays title partner according to Martin
a crucible is a big test obviously
referring to the wrong crime popped a
beast and through and if you want to
keep it merry little a crucible also use
the months away all that tanky bulls on
a piece of metal tomorrow that's left
it's pure uncut top grade steel so it's
a place in a prop there's the purity
that comes out of all this crooked ass
mess are we supposed to put it all on
the line for our beliefs
maybe but truth is John's death doesn't
prove nothing to nobody you better not
forget what Reverend Hale say that
Elizabeth and the last act of the play
clean to no faith when faith brings
blood it is a mistaken law that leads
you to sacrifice life woman life is
God's most precious gift no principle
however glorious may justify the taking
of it don't be a player here to get
yourself some [ __ ] no swag and tell your
mama to subscribe piece players
[Music]